[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily the
death of george floyd what defendant may
soon take the stand in the federal trial
of the three ex-officers plus the
so-called soho grifter people are
penting a public picture of me as a
criminal what she has to say about the
netflix series chronicling her crime
spree and the trial of the daytona beach
killer would it be fair to say that
hundreds of dna samples were collected
yes it was but first eight years after a
deadly movie theater shooting opening
statements are finally presented should
chad olson have grabbed a bag of popcorn
and tossed it on the defendant
no of course not
the evidence will show you can't shoot
and kill another person over there long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin testimony is underway in the
trial of a former police captain accused
of killing a man in a movie theater
after an argument over light from a cell
phone law and crime's angel levy is here
with what the jury heard from both sides
in opening statements
brian curtis reeves faces a
second-degree murder charge in the
shooting death of chad olson reeves shot
olson back in 2014 in a movie theater
and claims he acted in self-defense the
prosecutor says reeves was angry that
chad olson was on his cell phone around
the time a message appeared on the big
screen telling people to turn off their
cell phones scott rosenwasser told
jurors the lights were still up in the
theater at the time when reeves told
olson to turn off his phone the
confrontation unfolded from there
you're going to learn from a witness
that the defendant's tone was kind of
demanding
turn your cell phone off
now at that point the evidence will show
you they're kind of taken aback by this
now chad olson did not turn his phone
off now here's what you're going to
learn what was going on on that phone
he was looking at facebook
social media there was a website that he
was looking at
through facebook
and they had been looking at it
the evidence will show you of course
that's no reason to shoot another man
but here's what you're going to learn
that the defendant leans all the way
forward tells chad olson to turn his
phone off chad olson doesn't turn his
phone off right away now in a perfect
world
should chad also turned his phone off
yes
now the prosecution says reeves actions
were not self-defense and that he acted
out of anger and ill-will but the
defense says this wasn't just about
olson throwing popcorn they say that
reeves felt threatened and acted in
self-defense
let's talk about mr reeves all right
27-year police veteran you're the jury
you know what your job is the prosecutor
doesn't have to prove
um homicide here
they have to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that it was not justifiable use of
force
they have to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that mr reeves knowing what he
knew
being in that circumstance
beyond a reasonable doubt that he didn't
act reasonably
now jurors watched surveillance video
from inside the movie theater after
listening to opening statements and they
will also hear from chad olson's wife
who was sitting next to him at the time
that all of this unfolded back in 2014
we'll have that testimony for you on the
next edition of law and crime daily
brian
thanks anjanet
joining us today is civil rights
attorney sue ann robinson and terry
oster discuss this murder in a movie
theater suanne during opening statements
the prosecution highlighted the
differences between the video and
reeve's statement to the police how
strong of an opening was it
i think the prosecution's opening was
very strong because they're able to give
jury the context that they need because
the defense is arguing justifiable for
self-defense they have to create a
context and show the jury that this was
not a setting where it would be
reasonable for reeves to feel that his
life was in danger to the extent that he
would use deadly force he's like he's in
a movie theater with a guy who's
watching a movie with his wife they have
a young child they're trying to spend
some time together because they're they
have a young child like this is just a
family outing this isn't a rowdy bar
this isn't a setting where someone
should feel that they need to use deadly
force and i think in that regard they
were very strong i think they need to
harp in on
the fact that they the jury has a duty
to to find that his actions were
reasonable not whether it was possible
that he was scared or possible that he
thought the popcorn was a threat but
whether or not it was reasonable and if
i think they can get that message to the
jury they can hit a home run absolutely
now terry the prosecution tried to
attack the he's an elderly man argument
how did the defense handle that in their
opening
well brian i think they spent half their
opening talking about the fact that he
is an elderly man they said he was
retired that he's no longer physically
able to handle his job in addition to
the wife testifying his children are
going to come in and testify and say he
could no longer get up and that he
couldn't handle playing with the
children so he also spent a good amount
of time talking about the number of
medical experts who are going to come in
and testify and say that he has
degeneration of the back and the hip so
basically he's trying to say he was in
fear of serious bodily injury and that
is why he responded the way he did
yeah engineer terry kind of touched on a
bit but want to ask you more on this
what expert testimony does the defense
plan to present
well brian they are going to call an
expert in use of force so they will have
someone testifying about that and as
terry mentioned there will be an expert
on aging and she will discuss what
happens to someone's body as they age
things degenerate you know and that
could be mentally and physically so we
are looking to see whether or not that
will tie into this whole idea that
reeves even though he's a big guy may
have felt threatened all right we'll see
how this case continues make sure to
check out the trial on the law and crime
network and in california popular rapper
kodak black and three others are
recovering after being shot over the
weekend near a west hollywood restaurant
hosting a party for justin bieber
black's lawyer posted about the shooting
on his instagram page saying it was an
unprovoked attack police said there was
an altercation early saturday morning
between several people which led to the
shots being fired they say the suspect
fled the scene and that the shooting was
not gang-related all four people who
were shot were treated at the hospital
black's attorneys say he was shot in the
leg and that his injuries were not
life-threatening los angeles police say
the shooting was all caught on video and
they are still looking for a suspect
still ahead on law and crime daily the
woman dubbed the soho grifter speaks out
after netflix releases a series about
her crime spree
but first the trial of the daytona beach
serial killer we take you inside the
courtroom for day two of testimony
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
monday marked day two of testimony in
the florida trial of accused serial
killer robert hayes a man accused of
killing three women 15 years ago hayes
allegedly shot and killed laquita
gunther julie green and ijuana payton in
2005 and 2006. authorities say the three
women were sex workers prosecutors say
at the time investigators discovered a
pattern between each murder on monday a
retired detective who investigated the
daytona beach deaths took the stand
telling the jury about the evidence in
the case and the connections between the
three deaths
there was a connection between miss
gunther and a connection between miss
patton
the foreign dna dna that was located at
the patent
scene and the dna that the foreign dna
that was located
and the gun their dna was located in her
mouth okay and what was significant
again as a detective what was
significant about those those two dnas
that were found
i have two homicide scenes with dna
connected connecting both scenes one and
three and did you also have a
significant lead from the ballistic
evidence located at the second and the
third homicide yes the shell casing that
was located
at miss
green's crime scene
also was connected ballistically through
the shell casing that was located at
miss patton number three's crime scene
all right back to break down the daytona
killers uh or alleged serial killers
case is terry austin terry
we can call hayes an alleged serial
killer but no one in court can why do
you think that is and did the judge get
this right
i do think the judge got this right and
the rationale behind it is he doesn't
want it to be too prejudicial words have
meaning and if you say serial killer
then the jury is going to think to
themselves that this is a serial killer
so he made that ruling he also made a
ruling that the prosecution could refer
to a fourth victim that is rachel bay
she was killed in palm beach the other
three deaths occurred in daytona beach
but he also said that you could not
discuss the fact that she was strangled
because again he said that was too
prejudicial so in the back of his mind
he's weighing the pros and the cons and
he's thinking about whether it's
probative whether it's prejudicial and
if it's prejudicial he is not going to
let it in because he does not want to
set himself up for an appeal so i think
he's probably making the right decisions
in this case all right let's go to the
kind of the facts in the case now i
believe one and three are connected
through dna that i guess the
prosecution's gonna point to haze and
two and three are connected through
striations of the bullets we'll learn
more about that through ballistics uh so
how is the defense's argument that this
isn't hayes working out
you know i think they're going to have a
difficult time saying it's going to be
someone else because any time you have
dna connecting someone to the bodies the
jury's going to look at that and say
look this is the individual and if you
have the stridations connecting to the
bodies that too is going to be something
the jury is going to put their hat on
and say okay look these bullets match
the dna match you're not gonna have to
have three for three or four for four as
long as you have something on each one
of those individuals yeah and it does
kind of connect them if you do the one
to three the three back to two you can
tell that there's something that
connects them all even though there may
not be a connection between one and two
it'll be interesting to see how the
prosecution connects the dots in that
this case of florida versus robert hayes
and monday marks the four year
anniversary of the deadly marjory
stoneman douglas high school shooting in
parkland florida 17 were killed and 17
more injured when nicholas cruz opened
fire at the school cruz has since pled
guilty to charges connected to the
shooting the
penalty phase for cruz is set to begin
in april
coming up on law and crime daily who may
soon take the stand in the federal trial
of 3x officers charge in the death of
george floyd plus from the upper east
side to behind bars hear from the
disgraced soho socialite anna sorokin on
the netflix series inventing anna
[Music]
welcome back we're hearing from the
so-called soho grifter anna sorokin who
for years went by the name anna delvey
defrauding thousands of dollars from new
york's elite sorkin writes an open
letter following the release of the
netflix series inventing anna
chronicling the rise and fall of her
scheme
her name is anna delphi or anna sorokin
no one's short she's either on rich
german heiress or she's flat broke the
charges are insane
committed real white-collar felonies
while posing as a socialite in an
attempt to steal millions of dollars
i am famous
people are penting a public picture of
me as a criminal that's not my story
sorkin was arrested back in 2017 and
charged with grand larceny in the first
second and third degree as prosecutors
say she swindled new york's rich and
famous out of thousands of dollars in
2019 she was sentenced to four to 12
years in prison on top of a 24 thousand
dollar fine in order to paint nearly 200
000 in restitution right now sorkin is
being held in ice custody after a judge
ruled she was quote a continuous danger
to the community after overstaying her
visa sora consoles her life rights to
netflix for more than 300 thousand
dollars she told a reporter for
cosmopolitan quote it's weird to watch
your own life owned by someone else
while watching parts of the series in a
letter written from behind bars sorakan
maintains overstaying her visa was quote
unintentional and largely out of control
admittedly i the ultimate unreliable
narrator have made some questionable
choices that i wouldn't necessarily
repeat today
civil rights attorney sue ann robinson
and co-host terry austin join us as we
discuss the latest true crime story to
hit netflix terry had you heard of the
so-called soho grifter before this if
not what was your reaction to the story
i vaguely recall this story now that we
are talking about it it's all coming
back to me and my impression is that she
is a very charming individual she was
able to convince manhattan's elite that
she was part of that elite group and
they helped her to finance her lifestyle
basically she is a con man she committed
fraud i'm glad she was arrested and
convicted and served some time and it
she may defeat it and i think that's
probably the right thing to do because
i've not seen anything that says she
would not do this again if she had that
opportunity
that's quite the lifestyle that she
lived for those four years in jail
suanne sorkin got 300 000 for the rights
to her story is it fair that she's able
to profit from her crimes
well there are laws that prevent
defendants from profiting from notoriety
from their crimes i think in this
particular case for sure because it's a
financial crime for her to be able to
profit from it from it is almost like a
double whammy like she gets to hurt the
victims twice
i think that um you know terry's
absolutely right she's shown no remorse
she has she
literally says i am not sorry for this i
just regret i would have i would do some
of the things differently but i am not
sorry and so i think because of that i
definitely don't think it's appropriate
for her to be able to profit off of
something that she's gone to prison for
yeah i was kind of surprised when i
heard that she got that money there are
so many they're called son of sam laws
throughout the country that prevent this
uh i think we actually saw something
similar to that in the mod arbory trial
the judge said they can't profit off the
case but that's how it went for uh for
this case thank you both when we come
back the federal trial of three
ex-minnesota cops charged in the death
of george floyd who he could soon expect
to take the stand as the prosecution
wraps up its case
welcome back to law and crime daily a
new ruling from a federal judge says
elaine maxwell's fight for a new trial
must be publicized and cannot be kept
private despite the former british
socialized request to have them sealed
maxwell was convicted of sex crimes in
federal court last month including
trafficking and conspiring to recruit
and groom young teenage girls to be
abused by her former companion jeffrey
epstein after the trial ended a juror
revealed to news outlets that he told
others in deliberations that he had been
sexually abused as a child maxwell's
attorneys have filed for a dismissal and
a new trial because of it the juror's
pre-trial questionnaire is sealed but
multiple news outlets report he checked
a box saying neither he nor a loved one
had been a victim of sexual abuse in the
past maxwell's request to keep her
emotions for a new trial under seal was
denied by u.s district judge allison
nathan who said doing so would not be in
the public interest and would not
violate maxwell's right to a fair trial
there's no word yet on if she will get a
new trial
a jury is seated and opening statements
are presented in the federal trial of
the man of the men convicted of
murdering a mod arbory on monday jurors
heard opening statements as gregory
mcmichael travis michael and william
roddy bryan stand trial on the charges
of federal hate crimes all three men
were convicted last fall in connection
to aubrey's 2020 death at the time the
25 year old black man was going for a
jog near his brunswick georgia home
father and son duo gregory and trousy
michael tailed aubrey in a pickup truck
claiming they believed he was
responsible for a series of robberies in
their neighborhood travistic michael
eventually shot and killed aubry
claiming a sense of repeal to replace
citizen's arrest law
brian followed along in his own truck
and recorded the incident on video all
three were sentenced to life in prison
brian is eligible for parole after 30
years served the federal trial is
expected to last up to 10 days
in federal trial in minnesota the
prosecution rests its case after weeks
of testimony in the case of three former
officers charged in the death of george
floyd
ex-minnesota cops two tao thomas lane
and j alexander king are on trial at the
federal level for allegedly depriving
floyd of his constitutional rights when
they failed to give him medical help or
intervene when their fellow former
officer derek chovin knelt on his neck
floyd died shortly after the incident
and shown was convicted for his murder
on monday a use of force expert
testified quote any reasonable officer
in a scene like this would know that
there's a specific responsibility to
stop what they saw taking place in front
of them in regards to chauvin's actions
as the case moves to the hands of the
defense lane plans to testify in his own
defense lane is the only defendant not
charged with failure to intervene
presumably because he asked chauvin
multiple times to change floyd's
position king lane and tao also face a
separate state trial in connection to
floyd's death that's set to happen in
june
suen prosecutions rested now we're kind
of looking ahead lane is expected to
testify what do you expect to hear from
him and could we hear from the other
defendants
i expect lane is going to testify and
say that you know he attempted to
intervene which is why he wasn't charged
with failing to intervene because he was
questioning chauvin and saying hey
change
positions i think that's going to be his
kind of saving grace
however i don't know if it saves him
from what he's actually charged with i
think it definitely shows that he was
willing to question what was happening
that he had concern on the scene but it
doesn't show and we all know obviously
the end result is that he didn't stop
the chain of events that led to george
floyd's death yeah it's a question of
what he asked for and what he did see
how the jury interprets that terry have
you seen any holes in the prosecution's
case that the defense may be able to
create some reasonable doubt
i do think that the prosecution has a
very strong case here brian they have to
show willfulness remember we are in
federal court here and as suanne said
they've all been charged with failure to
provide aid and lane was the only one
not charged with failing to intervene so
i think the defense for lane has a
better case to make some arguments
particularly if he does get on the stand
to say look i tried to intervene i tried
to get
to move and turn the body i
even tried to render some medical aid he
tried to increase the
urgency of that call to the ambulance
and he ultimately did get into the
ambulance i don't think that
tau and lane or king rather have strong
defenses all right we'll see how those
goes as this case continues the defense
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you